-Our next guest is a
Tony Award-nominated actress
you know from shows like
"Only Murders in the Building"
and "The Idol."
She stars in "The Holdovers,"
which is in theaters now.
Let's take a look.
-And neither of them
made it to 25.
My baby wasn't even 20.
-I'm so sorry.
-I took this job...
when Curtis was small
because I wanted to ensure
that he was going
to have a good education.
You know he flourished here?
-Yes.
No, he was a great kid.
I had him one semester.
Very insightful.
-Mm-hmm.
He hated you.
He said you were
a real ass[bleep].
-Well, uh, like I said...
[ Chuckles ]
...sharp kid, insightful.
[ Laughter ]
-Please welcome to the show
Da'Vine Joy Randolph, everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Welcome to the show, Da'Vine.
How are you?
-I'm good. I'm in New York
at the perfect time.
-It is a good time to be here.
-The trees are up,
the lights are up.
-And you like this?
-Yes.
-Okay, good.
-To watch.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-To watch. Okay.
-Right, because it's now like,
okay, it's holidays now.
-Yeah.
I feel like they just put it up
like yesterday.
-Yeah. It just went up.
I like it less because
I have to come here every day.
-Yeah. You got to
fight through the crowds.
-...and you're like,
"Oh, my God! Christmas!"
And then you get to leave and
don't have to worry about it.
-Yeah.
-And every day I'm like,
"Why are all these people
at my office?"
-Yes, yes.
[ Laughter ]
-This is a beautiful film.
It's a wonderful holiday film
as well.
It's about Paul Giamatti
is a teacher
who stays at the school
for kids
who can't leave
for the holidays.
You are the woman
who works in the cafeteria,
and it's basically
the three of you,
you and Paul and a student.
It's a beautiful film.
It feels like it was made
in the '70s.
-Yeah.
-There's all these
lovely touches, but I imagine
while you were making the movie,
you wouldn't know what it was
going to look like
when it was done.
-No, so Alexander Payne does
something very I think amazing.
He doesn't use Video Village.
Video Village is like
with these monitors you can see,
you know, like, what's
going on --
-In between takes, you can go
back and see how the last one
looked.
-None of it.
And so he literally
is in the room filming
and then he has his face
right --
so the camera's here
and his face is right here.
And he'll be like,
[whispers] "Action."
-Wow.
-It's -- You know what I mean?
Because, you know,
you're used to like, "Action!"
-'Cause they're way far away.
-Yeah.
So it's like
it's very intimate.
It feels like this very
fly-on-the-wall type thing
and we're just being.
And so we had no idea -- Like,
you know, our clothes were like,
oh, okay, so our clothes
look vintage-y
and we're in these, like,
old abandoned buildings.
But you have no idea,
and then you see the movie
and you're like, "Whoa."
-Yeah, you really feel
like this could have
been made in the '70s.
-We really transported there.
And I think also the city
of Boston is perfect
for that, too,
you know what I mean?
And like, the more you get
northern of like northeast,
it's timeless.
-So those are people
that are resistant to change.
-Yes!
[ Laughter ]
-They're like, "We got it right.
We're not going to make it
a lot fancier."
-Yes.
-You want fancy go down south.
So another thing I heard is that
you working in the kitchen,
you told Alexander Payne
that you wanted to actually
physically cook the food.
-Yeah.
So I really love to cook,
and I just,
I needed something
with my hands
and I knew that it would
ground me in the character.
And so in the movie
there is a soup, oatmeal,
like she's prepping and
chopping up all the vegetables,
a roasted chicken, and, like,
a big pot of scrambled eggs
as like the hangover meal
or whatever.
And I loved all of it.
And he was so kind.
He basically was like, "Okay,
what is the Christmas menu?"
And so I get to pick out
what the Christmas menu
was and all the trimmings.
And then they had --
There's a series called "Julia,"
like the Julia Child series.
-Yes, of course.
-I think it was on HBO.
And the people from there
worked with us,
and so I got to just like,
geek out on, like,
food nerdy stuff.
-Very nice.
-Yeah. And we swapped, like,
recipes and stuff like that.
And then, yeah,
we cooked it all
and it was all great
except for the oatmeal.
-Really?
-Yes.
-Don't take this the wrong way,
that's one of the
easier things you listed.
[ Laughter ]
-No, because after doing
several takes,
oatmeal starts getting thick.
It's like a plaster.
-Yeah. Yeah, no. Right.
-After five takes
and I'm, like, trying to do it
and, like,
make it look seamless.
Sometimes it got stuck.
The spoon got stuck in there.
So that was the only one
that I was like,
"Oh, I should have rethought
that one."
-So, you would tell actors,
you should definitely
cook your own food,
but fake it with the oatmeal.
-Yeah, yeah.
-Okay, great.
-Yeah, the oatmeal is too much.
-You also have to smoke
in the movie.
This did not come
as natural as the...
-No, no.
I am not a smoker at all.
I'm a vocalist, so no, no, no.
And he -- That was something
when we first talked about it,
he was like,
"Just so you know,
you're holding it down
with the smoking."
-Yeah.
-He has a pipe,
you got the cigs.
And I was like,
"Oh, well, I don't smoke."
And he was like, "You have
a package coming in two days."
And he must have like express
shipped two large boxes
of cartons full of cigarettes.
-Okay.
-Fake ones.
-Okay, good. Yeah.
-And as I was doing
the fake ones,
I was like,
"This isn't cutting it,"
because it was --
like, the smoke would, like,
plume out like it was a cigar
and it would cover my face up.
-Yeah.
-And I would still be talking,
but like a big cloud of smoke
is over my face.
And I was like, "Well,
that's not going to work."
And so I was nervous that
I was going to get addicted.
-Yeah.
-So, like, I tried
different brands and I was like,
"Oh, that might get me addicted.
That one, that one."
And then it was like, I think
it's called like American Trade.
-Okay.
-Is that the one?
Or American Spirit.
-Yes, yes, yes.
-Yes. The blue one.
The blue one.
That was like the perfect dosage
where I was like, "Okay,
I can do this.
I'm not going to get addicted,
and it's real
so it's going to look real."
And so I would ask people
who smoked like,
"Does this look right?"
I would watch old movies.
-Oh that's good.
Who's the best old movie...?
-Bette Davis.
-Bette Davis, Bette Davis.
-Great.
She has it on lock.
So I would, like,
constantly have a cigarette,
because it's a choreography
of knowing when to pull it,
to drag it,
and then do you hold it?
Can we start talking now?
Do I release it now?
Am I going to do,
like, the weed
like [raspy muttering]
like that?
No, it's the '70s
and that wouldn't make sense.
So I was like, "I got to figure
this out,"
and like, you know,
to try to track, like,
okay, well,
she's upset right now,
so she's going through
these cigs faster
than in other situations.
So it was
a really cool, fun thing
to just have --
-That's amazing.
-Yeah, that and dialect.
It was just like
great anchors for me.
-It's fantastic because
I will say it is
the most naturally acted movie
by all of you.
-Thank you.
-And now I'm going to go back
and watch it and realize like,
"Oh, my God,
all she's thinking about
is oatmeal and cigarettes."
-Yes! Exactly!
-That's literally all --
She's like,
"Smoke, stir, smoke, stir."
-Smoke, smoke, smoke, smoke.
-Aah!
It's a wonderful film.
You're receiving Oscar buzz,
knock on wood,
but deservedly so.
-Thank you.
-Thanks for being here.
-You guys,
That's Da'Vine Joy Randolph.
"The Holdovers" in theaters now.
We'll be right back
with more "Late Night."